e
we got a lot to do today and it's 10
o'clock so uh I think we should get
started um we have 10 bills and and like
what four hours to do them in or
something like that so uh is anyone here
337 no oh okay here we go please uh
more here to offer myself up for
questions my name is um Rob Barry I'm
general counsil of division of Medicaid
I did hear your conversation about how
much Medicaid I was trying to find that
in the fiscal Network sheet from uh last
session I hadn't pulled that up yet um
but it is correct that this was part of
um hb2 uh this part was left out of hb2
last year and this is more of a cleanup
um piece of legislation so I'm happy to
take any questions you might have so
speak a little slower you're sorry um
I'm also fighting a cold so
apologize for my voice um last year um
there oh Rob Barry Rob Barry General
Council Division of Medicaid division of
etiquette Medicaid Medicaid oh I'm not
hearing you yeah it's all right sorry
hearing there you go all right okay fine
thank you last year uh a Bill had been
introduced uh known as the momus bill
that included this lactation Dulla um uh
language it had been incorporated into
hb2 this portion here in s337 was
inadvertently left out of the
incorporation into
hb2 uh and that's why we're here today
it's clean up legislation to um to
incorporate this provision uh and this
is necessary so Medicaid can be build is
essentially it okay committee have any
questions for Mr
Barry representative
what does a doula do that needs training
and
certification so I don't have my
licensing person with me uh but my
understanding is a dla is somebody who's
specifically trained in um providing
well so Carol me Carol talked to me
about this because I think this came
from her committee and she said said
that often um young
mothers sometimes don't have their
mother around or don't have some uh
experienced woman around to help them uh
learn how to breastfeed correctly I
guess and that's what the purpose of
these people are correct yes it's more
focused on the after care I believe yep
after
birth represent evil did you have a
question yes I I know don't have a
question I mean I'm I'd like to make a
motion to pass the bill go ahead OTP
thank you and there's a second from
representative Sweeny any discussion all
right uh clerk may call the role okay
the the clerk just made the motion so
I'm going to get my act together here
okay
so the motion is ought to pass on HB
um uh representative
Maguire um please call me last and call
Representative Griffin first okay okay
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes repres chair
Wier yes clerk votes yes uh
representative Lane yes representative
grassy yes uh okay this is going to get
all screwy here representative walner
yes okay and vice chair Maguire yes okay
all right so it
unanimous Eble
due to scheduling uh weirdness our next
one is not scheduled to
10:20 so
um I don't know if that you know are we
obligated to wait or yes okay oh well
it's in the
calar I I'll just mention something
about this bill that that sort of bugged
me okay since we're sort of on this bill
and that is
um where is it
here maybe it wasn't this
[Music]
one yes so it's line um
11 the office shall make every effort to
include racially and geographically
so this to me reads like it's
unconstitutional
right the one we we're talking about
337 duelist yeah the one we already
decided to pass but this is just the
line that bugs me is that um shall
include you know they they're supposed
to use race right but but don't we have
all kinds of laws and so on that says
you can't use race you first stuff
exactly
so so I'm not comfortable with that but
I
don't I just mention it because I don't
think it's going to make any real
difference
yeah yeah it's just don't give all my
amendments for today have to do with
you yeah I guess could do a floor
Amendment
anyways that's that all right well we'll
20one
e
it is
10:20 is anyone here to talk about uh
369 office of professional lure and
certification providing notice of public
meetings an opportunity for comment
creating a new position and making an
appropriation
therefore all right please come forward
good morning members of the committee
for the record Lindsay Courtney
executive director
oplc um so as as you recall this is uh
very similar to the bill that you passed
last year um which was House Bill 337
which the governor vetoed um citing some
concerns specifically with
administrative burden and deviations
from 91a um what we did is we went back
uh to the drawing table we made a few
changes um and I think it's something
that we can all agree um can work and um
we take no position on the bill but um
we're ready to implement it should uh
should the legislature decide to
pass so any questions for Miss Courtney
and congratulations on your upcoming
promotion there thank you very much
representative uh yes representative
Sweeny I would move on to pass okay all
right I guess there's no
question okay all right the clerk can
sec
OTP okay
when will that
coun okay uh the motion is ought to pass
on HB
369 representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Camrose yes chair Wier
yes uh clerk votes yes representative
Lane yes representative grassy yes
representative walner yes representative
90 Sweeny and
I
Evil all right do we have another 20
[Music]
minutes
e
excent all right so we are on Senate
Bill
that Senator r
no yeah do you want to tell us what this
is
about this bill but for you thank you Mr
chair um is a strip down
and um stripped down policy-wise and
cost-wise
version of what was introduced in the
Senate it does basically three things it
extends the commission on Primary Care
Workforce which is about to expire it
allows more
lnas to
administer
medication and it sets up a
process for voluntary
certification of community health
workers these um individuals are really
important to the Health Care
System but they are not clinical staff
they are uh Personnel who
have sort of lived experience with the
communities they work in they work in
community health centers
hospitals and um at least in nashwa they
work in the public health
department and what they do do
is they they do a lot of the
administrative work so that licensed
Health Care Professionals can actually
work to the scope they are licensed for
so doctors and nurses don't need to be
arranging transportation to medical
appointments or helping with food
assistance
that is the job that a community health
worker can do so the nurse and the
doctor can
do nursing and
Medicine however because they are not
certified now they are not able to be
reimbursed by either Medicaid or
commercial
insurance so by setting up this process
they would become
able to be reimbursed in the commercial
Market of course that would be subject
to contract
negotiation between a carrier and the
employer we also took the
appropriation to sustain this important
workforce out of the bill because the
Department of Health and Human Services
already has the money they need from
federal grants and in fact last month in
the fiscal committee we
transferred just under $2
million to support the community health
workers so there's no State cost it is
not an ongoing solution but the
hospitals the Family Resource
Centers the community health
centers think they're a really important
part of their
Workforce and would like to be able to
keep them so that Physicians and nurses
can work at the top of their scope thank
committee representative
walner thank you um Senator
rosenal so your your um the bill will be
funded through arpa funds that fiscal
has already acted on is that correct I
don't think it's arpa funds I think it
might be a different Federal grant but
it will be funded through Federal grant
funds that
HHS already has that's why there's no
appropriation we were able to take it
out because the department had the money
and we've already
transferred most of
it um to fund this Workforce for the
next year thank
you representative wner I said
representative Wier excuse me thank you
Mr chairman uh thank you Senator when I
first read it it sounds like this is
dealing with foreign populations but
there's no requirement to be language
proficient to get this C ification and
do we have that many is there that large
a foreign population that can't
understand English
well 10% of the population of nashwa is
from India we have also a a large and
growing Latino population and we've
had I moved to NASA 35 years a ago and
there was a significant Brazilian
population at the time it it's it's not
only language-based it's communities of
elderly people who are more homebound
who are also helped and it's also young
families who are more at risk who are
um clients let's say of the Family
Resource Centers so it
it's I think it would be not correct to
say we're only talking about people who
speak Spanish it's some people who speak
Spanish but it's some people who um know
that just know the community some people
who are good with the elderly or with
you right um so Senator do Melissa give
her the latest fiscal note oh she asked
okay um so what I'm concerned with is if
you look under expenditures on our as
amended by the house fiscal note which
we just got it says in 2025 4.25 million
Source federal arpa funds comma state
general funds
and the way I read this that's an
ongoing
cost is that
right well I it's a subject to a budget
appropriation like everything else in
the next budget so I don't read it that
way oh
so you're thinking that we could pass it
now they could work for a year and then
we could pull their funding back I mean
that
seems I think we could um you know hope
that we continue to get federal grants
we could discuss using general funds we
have all the options that we always have
at our
disposal but they uh their grant funding
that they currently have runs
out like next month so this will keep
them
employed for the next year and then all
the options are ours we might decide not
to include their funding in the Medicaid
budget we might continue to receive
Federal grant money I mean I just don't
think we can predict
that okay represent
walner so it sounds to me like from your
description of the work that um the
community health workers do it sounds to
me like that actually as far as the
Medicaid budget goes they're providing
I'm sure at a a less reimbursement than
a nurse or a doctor so in a way they are
sa they are
saving Health Care
money I think you could look at it that
way I mean right now they're getting
zero reimbursement so um this would
allow and we've already train
transferred for federal
funds to um help sustain this Workforce
in the short
term by
increasing the availability in the
primary care setting I think we save
money through the entire Health Care
system so if doctors and nurses can see
more people at a community health center
I think we could project I don't have
the numbers but I think we could guess
that might mean fewer emergency
department visits fewer hospital
assumption what would happen if we
delayed this issue till the budget next
time where it could be considered by
division 3 you know more properly than
us well I think that we would lose the
services of these workers for the next
fiscal year because we've TR I mean
we've made the money available but we
haven't started the certification
process if we delay it till the next
budget it won't just start on July 1st
of
2025 we'll
be 3/4 of the way through the next
budget before those rules are written
and adopted so I think that it makes
sense to do this policy piece now
knowing that there is not a state cost
and we have the
option to fund it or not fund it or fund
all right um so I uh I prepared an
amendment that would thank you thank you
Senator um I prepared an amend is there
anyone by the way from HHS here yes
would you like to
come
please good
morning good morning my name is Athena
Cody and I'm with the Department of
Health and Human Services Division of
Public
Health and I'm Christa Morris I'm with
the division yes Department of Health
and Human Services sorry I'm
tired thanks so
uh please um the two questions I mainly
asked the senator I would like you to um
confirm is it so that there is no
General funds in this bill for you know
budget that the money has already been
provided by the fiscal committee or or
is from internal money that you already
have extra there's no addition oh sorry
I didn't realize how loud that would be
um the the current funding is is already
appropriated within contracts um and uh
through fiscal year
25 so through the end of the current
budget yes yeah okay and what would be
the consequence of delaying the
certification to the next budget putting
essentially putting this language in the
next house build too the certification
piece from from my knowledge um has has
been an ongoing work um that has been um
something that we've really tried to
look at happening um but it's a way for
reimbursing for services and not being
solely um relying on grant funding uh
this would allow some Medicaid
reimbursement it's not going to cover
all of the FTE or the the the um the
full salary for a community health
worker but it'll at least help to um for
these agencies like community health
centers and Family Resource Centers to
be able to start planning some other
sources of funding this will definitely
help to reimburse for some of those
Services ongoing so it kind of sets us
planning represent wner yeah so
presently if these um Community Health
Providers are not um
certified they're not eligible for
Medicaid reimbursement so we do not
receive the federal share
uh currently there there is no
certification but in the future it's
totally voluntary so so if a chw does
not go through the process they would
not be eligible for Medicaid
reimbursement and so the Medicaid
reimbursement does allow for some
guidelines um that could be monitored
okay and so just so I'm clear in order
for a community health worker to be
reimbursed with Medicaid funds they have
have to be certified is that right this
would be the process yes and this is the
process yes thank you
yeah who's who's providing the grants
that are paying them
now there there are a variety of Grants
um some from the center from for Disease
Control um Health disparities Grant some
are um epidemiology and and capacity
building um I didn't write all the
grants down but um there are various
federal grants that also come to a close
and so um we are interested in
sustainability of the
workforce so so you don't expect to get
these grants continuing no and that's
why you want to move these people onto
being paid by Medicaid yeah these grants
are all coming to a close um right now
we're in a um we've we've had approval
for a no cost extension for a couple of
them um so so they'll they'll
end okay so is it fair to say we're
making a decision here as to whether if
we continue this
Workforce the state will end up paying
half because we pay half of
Medicaid versus right now the state's
this so in our fiscal note it actually
states that the 4.2 million that are
currently being used is a mix of federal
and general funds so right now some
general funds are being used
us that were in the budget or yes oh
okay I
see just to clarify the general funds or
some of the funds that are that go to
Family Resource Centers which supports a
variety of their infrastructure some of
those are are if they need coverage for
those positions for the chw positions is
that about half of these costs or is it
a little less or no it's it's a lot less
all right any other
questions no anyone else here like to
ladies uh good morning Mr chairman I'm
Jim Monahan with the dunk group and I'm
here
today um on behalf of a number of
community providers we have a Coalition
that's been working on this uh subject
matter in bill for a couple of his
sessions um so I don't want to lean in
heavily on the on the policy because I
know you're looking at the fal impact
but so let me um try to convince you not
to move forward with your Amendment
representative McGuire um um
particularly how it will affect the
community uh Mental Health Centers and
the community uh Health Centers the
federally qualified Health Centers um
they employ lots of community health
workers um it Exel cerate a lot uh as a
consequence of the uh healthc care work
short Workforce shortage that we've had
as representative I'm sorry Senator
rosenell indicated with the right
balance of community health workers
you're able to free up clinical staff to
have more direct contract with folks so
uh today those those um community health
workers because they don't have um a
certification they cannot be
credentialed by commercial insures and
so the uh their activity at the
community health center or Community
Mental Health Center uh is totally paid
for with uh the center's bake sale funds
I know that's not a fair way to describe
it but there there's no commercial or
Medicaid reimbursement for that activity
um so uh
uh that is among the there's certainly
other reasons around the professionalism
of the of the workforce that they stick
around and they become part of they work
their way through it so uh the concern
we have and as the finance committee is
well aware is that there is a a
significant challenge to operate the
Community Mental Health Centers and the
community health center so this is going
to help both from the professionalism of
that Workforce but frankly with regard
to reimbursement I don't think we'll be
in a situation where if uh we don't move
forward with this we'll just eliminate
that work for Force what we're really
doing is just leaving money on the table
whether it be for commercial
reimbursement for Medicare or Medicaid
without the certification so we try to
work this through the system uh it is a
voluntary certification so we're we're
trying to be mindful of not ex expanding
uh regulated health professionals uh if
we don't have to but it really gets into
this odd mix of the rules of the road
for reimbursement so are the skill
levels of this group less than an LNA
um yeah I want to be respectful of the
profession but yes I mean they don't
they're not so someone from this group
might future move up by becoming an LNA
oh absolutely yes yeah okay that's part
of the you know I don't want to have
this not the policy committee but the
the whole theory around the career
ladder that you bring people in uh in
the early stages of the career and
encourage them to be trained and and
move through the process thank you so
would anyone like to make a motion on
I'll move out to pass right is there a
[Music]
rooll all right the motion is ought to
pass on HB
403 representative Griff Rin no
representative Sweeny yes representative
Wier clerk votes yes representative Lane
yes representative grassy yes uh
representative walner
yes and representative Maguire
no so the vote is two three six to
right real estate
to real estate practice anyone here to
so good morning I'm Adam Schmidt I'm
lobbyist here in cochard we represent
the new hampsh Association Realtors and
as I'm looking at this it says exactly
what I hoped it would say which is there
is no fiscal impact at the policy
committee there was a provision that
talked about allocating funds to oplc
for additional staff that section was
removed in Edna so the portion of the
bill that actually spent money was
removed all that's left are policy
Provisions that are very technical and
deal with the real estate practice which
would just be very boring to have me
listen I try to explain but for this
committee's purposes the portion that
did allocate money was removed from the
bill as introduced all that was passed
on to you were again some more technical
Corrections for the real estate Practice
Act thank you any questions from the
committee representative Griffin well I
I kind of want to offer that uh I have
had a real estate or I had a real estate
license from age
19 and uh so I looked at this bill
pretty carefully it it it makes some
positive changes it
appears it appears
um it appears that it eliminates the
need to maintain an office and a bond if
you're
inactive uh if it also states that if
while you were in while you were active
if you uh earned a commission that that
can be paid if you become
inactive well it the commission for the
time you were active can be paid and uh
other than that basically it's it
appears to me be a lot of the things
that existed already and uh I would move
it uh representative Griffin has moved
out to pass seconded by representative
Sweeney the clerk will call the role
discussion okay uh representative
Griffin
yes
yes representative grassy yes
representative walner yes and
[Music]
yeah
e
yes thank you so it's 1120 Let's uh get
started on Senate Bill
407 establishing a ground ambulance
cost reporting program
Etc
um has no fcal impact according to our
latest as amended by the house anyone
want to tell us what this is about cuz I
tried to read this and I couldn't
up and state your names thank you good
morning I'm Michelle Heaton I'm the
director of Life and Health at the New
Hampshire insurance
department and I'm Alex Feld Vel the
health reform instructor at the New
Hampshire insurance department welcome
um what can you tell us about what this
does well um I'd like to take start by
taking a couple of minutes to give the
whole context out of which this bill
came absolutely um it comes out of um a
series of meetings dealing with ground
ambulance services and it's their
interface with commercial health
insurance that started last summer the
uh insurance commissioner
convened um what we called the ground
ambulance Summit and uh we had a lot of
representation from ambulance providers
from hospitals consumers and health
carriers to deal with two main issues um
one is the problem of balanced billing
um where people who are covered with
health insurance get surprised by um a
balance bill for ambulance services
because they don't don't realize that
their the ambulance is not in network
and therefore not constrained uh by the
reimbursement amount that it receives
from the health carrier it's the one
area that was not dealt with by the
federal no surprises act uh because it's
a little bit more complex than the other
instances of Balan billing that were
occurring so that's one problem that we
wanted to solve and the other problem
was the increasing Financial strain that
ambulance service providers are under
these days their costs are going up a
lot um and um traditionally um the
public payers have not paid very well uh
relative to the cost of producing the
services so we were trying to tackle
those two issues at the same
time and the um Department we sort of
finished up with the meetings we
couldn't reach consensus as a group but
the department insurance department did
produce a a report a final report on the
summit meetings which is on our website
and the essence of our recommendations
were um basically the commercial
insurers because that's what it was
about is the that percentage of the
payers um that ambulance service
providers have that consists of State
regulated commercial insurance which is
really only 10% of the payers most of
the payers are Medicare Medicaid
self-funded commercial coverage which is
not regulated by the state and then the
last 10% is the commercial
insurance um so our recommendation is
that that 10% the commercial insurers
should increase their reimbursement
rates to fully cover the cost of
providing ground ambulance services
including what cost what's called
Readiness of you know be making sure you
have sufficient resources to be
available
um and number two that balance billing
should be prohibited in exchange
um uh but in order to determine what
that uh cost-based fee schedule should
be uh it requires uh a study that
information I mean we made a sort of lay
person's attempt during the summit
meetings to put out a survey and gather
some
information um but uh we didn't get
usable information in that way so what's
needed to move toward this cost based
reimbursement system is um a
professional study with an actual cost
survey um done by accounting an
Actuarial firm plus the production of a
report and a illustrative fee schedule
so when house Commerce got this bill of
out of all the recommendations that the
insurance department has made they
picked out that one piece like the first
step and decided let's just do this
let's do it quickly so it's due December
1st of this year which is indeed a TI uh
Fe tight schedule um but um that's how
this um replace all Amendment came to
be I could pause there or I could
explain anticipates the question yes let
me just quickly the previous fiscal note
said that we were raising people's
Insurance costs by 11.8 million so
that's gone is that what you're saying
yeah the the version of the bill that
came over from the Senate was quite
different it sort of jumped over the
cost study and just picked a number uh
which was basically either whatever
ambulance providers charge or
325 of Medicare and so when we had to do
a fiscal note for that and you know from
our claims data which we used to do a
lot of analysis we saw that the current
rate is more like 120% of Medicare and
so we just used claims data to calculate
what the total cost would be to bring it
up to 325 per and then what would that
would mean on a per member per month
committee representative Lane I don't
have as much a question as I have
experienced the balance paid and
um considering that we had no choice in
who we picked um it it was it's a real
it's a huge issue for people so um do
you think that this is going to lead to
a solution of that
because that because it was a big
surprise well I appreciate your your
comment big surprise we get a lot of
complaints um in the last two years uh
we surveyed uh all the complaints about
balance billing we found that the median
balance bill was between $3 and
$4,000 and that uh 30% of them were
actually over
$6,000 um and when you compare that to
the fact um the enan policy Institute
reports that 27% of New Hampshire
residents have less than $2,000 in
emergency savings it's a real hardship
for some people certainly and it was a
top priority of the department to to get
to that issue yeah and I think when
we've been talking about this issue
throughout the summit and throughout
this legislative session trying to come
up with compromises the sticking point
is always well what percent are you
going to set it at what's the rate going
to be and and um I think all the parties
are at very opposite sides so this
independent analysis will help everyone
come up with an agreed upon rate that is
principles more
questions
no maybe representative Lane would like
to make a
oh thank you okay and seconded by
represent all right so representative
grassy moves and representative Sweeney
role Griffin
yeses
yes
e
all right thank you very much it's 11:40
and we are going to consider Senate Bill
487 I see commissioner Arling house here
about yes please
so so you're going to explain why uh
we're going to have to spend 350,000 a
year instead of 72,000 in a year just
because people are moving from one
building to another well it's it's not
quite like that
um the bill um first of all it's worth
noting that there's no appropriation
attached to this bill I don't want
anyone to think that
um I don't want the PAB in particular to
think that um they will get staff
because until money's appropriated
nobody gets nothing um so because that's
there's no appropriation in the billers
as I can tell um the the additional
money is an estimate of what an
independent PAB would cost and it
presumes they have a couple of people um
and that they right now basically the
the way the Personnel appeals board
works is is it
is it's an appellate body that is
fundamentally independent but not
legally independent it's it's an
afterthought of State government like
like a lot of these little things are
they're sort of an afterthought and
you're like well we're not really in
charge of you and you could argue for
example they rely upon the good graces
of the division of personnel to um let
them use their conference room and
Supply them such staff as they might
have as might have free time to help out
with various administrative duties and
that that's always been a source of some
degree of tension right between the two
organizations particularly given that we
are
typically on one side of their decisions
right we they're deciding between uh an
opinion that all often includes dop um
and somebody else so it's sort one of
these awkward things like you know I
don't work for you you no I know you
don't work for us but you know if you
want to use the conference room on
Wednesday you got to ask somebody um and
so there's all of that so for a long
time um they've wanted to be independent
this is this is a something the the
board itself has wanted for a long time
and so they did so what does
independence look like Independence
looks like you are actually an
independent agency like a lot of other
little tiny things that are attached to
um in most cases unfortunately us um but
like the Commission on Aging has one and
a half people the child advocate has I
think six at this point the special ed
Advocate has one soon to be two the
conservation
land
stewardship it's not trust what's I
think just conservation land stewardship
the sort of flatsome that when we
abolished OSI was left over someone want
oh make them independent and attach them
there well what that happens is you get
a you get a signed State office space
and the way State office space works is
you get you get charged for it a rent-
likee charge and so that's an allocation
you get a doit allocation for the
computers that you use and so that's all
those costs amount to about this I think
our fiscal note I it's not the fiscal
note but if you looked at the fiscal
note worksheet that was provided it has
footnotes for where all those costs come
from uh like the Personnel line which be
um two- part-time positions there'd be
some expense to to you know put a desk
and a cubicle in an office um to set up
a room there'd be a copier a printer um
you'd have HR Support um and then just
those costs right now the costs are um
are only the very direct costs allocated
to the paab members in One accounting
unit that happens to be carried within
did you have a question no
questions represent of wiland just a
comment I've been impressed with how
often um conference rooms can be
multi-used because you know once a month
once a quarter it's pretty expensive
real estate to one agency no I think
it's I think it's an important thing I
you know we we uh you probably know this
that I I've said from the beginning that
that um from from when I started that
there's no such thing as a Das
conference room that we have three
conference rooms that that our agency
sort of controls the scheduling for and
they're routinely Human Rights
Commission used to always meet in room
405 of the annex which is quote unquote
our conference room and I remember
saying that to um agriculture once when
somebody wanted to use their conference
room I said it's not yours it's the
states and so generally then where I
would like to get eventually is where
adjudicative bodies because there are a
lot of little if you think about the
state these administrative the plrb is
one and the Human Rights Commission has
hearings and that although they're very
independent minded so they're probably
probably won't play ball but um housing
appeals board it's another thing that's
attached to admin services but there are
all these little things and nobody uses
a conference nobody uses a a hearing
room five days a week and so I P for
example has two big hearing rooms the
one of them they let everybody use PAB
actually has hearings there some times
um the other one they tend not to let
anybody else use cuz it has name plates
and they don't want anyone messing with
their stuff but I want to get to the
point where there's a building that has
all the boards of various sizes and has
like two rooms that everyone has to
reserve and that nobody gets to leave
their papers behind have have to take
them home at night or put them in their
office down the
hall yeah and you're you're redoing the
building right so everybody's moving out
soon
anyways yes the the annex is under is
about to my I'm told the first
Sledgehammer swings June 1st um
contracts done and and people are moving
out already from the annex um admin
services will have there seven seven
different agencies that have people in
the building and admin services will
have
about 7 108 to 115 people move out and
about 30 of us left behind the Secretary
of State um this is one of those
agencies it's very hard to exercise any
control over does not want to leave so
they won't um so they're going to say
treasury is's going to stay um the
governor's office I don't dare touch um
so they're they're Suite of offices over
there they're staying too I don't that's
sort of obnoxious I don't mean I don't
dare touch but you know I'm appointed by
the governor I'm not going to touch
him um 33 people moved to Pillsbury the
old van the van McLoud building um old
labor in the budget if if you're if
you're historically minded um and we're
moving 80 of them to the space
Corrections abandoned in the main
building so we did some painting and
stuff and vacuuming but it looks
nice so all right so if we pass this
bill can we expect in the next
budget this agency's cost will go up and
yours will go down by a similar amount
or not no ours will not go down by it
Sim moreon CU right now they're they're
I mean they they would be a real
independent agency that would get their
own office space arguably they're
entitled to it now to an extent rather
than being um vagabonds just setting up
in a conference room ours won't go down
simply because the the
people uh the people who are helping PAB
right now are not dedicated to helping
paab they're they're staff who do you
know like well let's have Linda do it
this week CU she has time and and why
don't you do the scheduling I why don't
you help with this and those people all
have you know jobs where they don't have
any free time anyway and you're just
hoping that on Wednesday they can do
that so you won't you won't really see
any any you won't see any reduction in
our budget you'll see an increase in
theirs can't you reorganize those people
slightly so that rather than this week
it's this person and this week it's that
person it's always this person and the
other people feeling we we could but the
the the truth is that to support PAB we
don't have sufficient staff now and so
what we're doing is doing the best we
can and so what you're asking everybody
is is it's essentially if I walked in
and said said you know what you guys
have to support the PAB you know the the
10 of you 10ish of you however many of
you there are and you're like well look
I got stuff to do I don't and I said
yeah tough cancel a hearing and make
time and so what we're doing and I'm not
saying that's a bad approach but it's
what we're doing now when someone said
um I know you don't have enough hours in
the day to do your job today I don't
care I need five more of your hours in a
week and we're just going to everybody's
going to do a little so we get there
when everybody stops doing that they
just have time to do the things that
now other questions no anybody like to
make a motion on this
representative
Griffin I'll move on to
pass representative Griffin moves at to
seconds you can call the um
representative
gin yes representa Sweeny
yes
all right please uh stay in your places
be
e
thank you for coming so we're going to
talk about Senate Bill 134 is anyone
here to talk about that besides
thank you representative Maguire um I
appreciate for the record my name is
you're welcome Mr car Marty Carlin
representing nhrs uh we don't have a
position on the bill I know this is a
workshop but there's a lot to this bill
and there's also revised fiscal analysis
so I wanted to come up and and kind of
give a summary of what the handout was
that you just received um and then the
the last Pages they would just cut off
the press from the actuary yesterday and
sent over to LBA after hours yesterday
so it hasn't caught up with the the bill
yet um for a fiscal note so essentially
what Senate Bill 134 would do is create
a new uh level of disability benefit in
nhrs for group two members uh violently
in attacked and injured on the job um
you know by um with a by means of a
deadly weapon
right now there are two existing types
for both member groups job related and
non-job related disability there's
different eligibility and different
benefit uh Provisions for each of those
they're they're referred to in the
statute as ordinary which is non-job
related and accidental uh which is job
related it doesn't have to be an
accident that's just the way that the
statute was constructed so this would
create a violent accidental disability
benefit um the bill has been ended
significantly since it uh was first
introduced last year and then we
referred to um Senate Edna and NH HRS um
worked with Senator birdell and other
agencies on the wording uh for the
current bill um primarily the the one of
the largest sticking points was the
eligibility what is the definition of a
violent assault and who attest to that
so um the department of safety uh
graciously agreed to um do that review
they already the commissioner already
certifies for line of duty death benefit
lumpsum payments under a separate
statute as well as some other uh pieces
so that took away an administrative
issue for
nhrs um the benefit amount formula is
different for this benefit um and again
this a a fiscal committee so I'm not
really going to go into huge detail here
unless anybody has any
questions um you know and there are a
couple of other changes including the
eligibility for a medical subsidy
benefit for these disability annuitants
uh Andor eligible family members um so
that's that's the gist there the fiscal
analysis the original bill um it was
sufficiently vague enough where the ACT
estimated a very high number of
accidental disabilities would be
qualified under this I think it said
like $10 million or something and that's
that's not true what the most recent did
and and this number is is again we'd
have to look on experience and see what
what's going to happen and it is sort of
scalable in your own mind if you want to
look at it and say that that that's too
high but they assume that 10% of group
two police job related disabilities
would fall under this and that may or
may not be too high but we had to pick a
number as a Baseline and 1% uh for fire
members so that's what the cost is shown
on the um the last page here pension
results State and political subdivision
so for instance if if you thought 1% of
disability inance we get this instead of
40,000 a year for this data would be
4,000 an extra contribution so very very
linear calculation um to to think about
that way
um right now there are currently um
about
445 uh accidental uh jab related
disability Anu currently receiving a Ben
pension from
nhrs uh 85 of those have um retired
since 71 of 18 which is a the date the
look back date in the bill for anybody
who's currently retired who thinks they
may qualified for this can reapply so
that's that's the the entire universe of
people who could um there may only be I
there's a couple of folks who have
testified in previous hearings and they
may be the only ones or there may be
others unaware of it or outside the loop
we have we wouldn't we have to review
all the records to see but um that
that's how that works um you know our
our longest um group two disability
benefit Inu it uh was disabled in 1968
and we've had
a about 150 prior to the year 2000 so um
you know it's a small pace of folks who
are even just injured on the job in
terms of disability grants
year-over-year and this this would be
expect expected to be significantly
rarer occurrence so um with that I'd be
glad to answer any questions all right
well I definitely appreciate the smaller
number but even
so you said you pick 10% and so 10% of
this 70 number would be about seven and
as I understand it only two are known
right so after a lot of looking they
found two is that correct yeah well this
this projects going forward as well so
so in other words you know there's
there's
340 police and 100 fire currently
receiving disability so you know 34 out
of you know 10% of 340 because you know
hopefully this is a rare or
non-occurrence going forward but
certainly by the nature of the work
they're projecting you know future folks
qualifying for this benefit as well it's
not just analyzing the the Retro piece
thank you um other questions for Mr
car I'm not seeing
anybody all right
um thank you do um and as I understand
it this is not um directly charging
General funds for you know it's not like
our our other retirement stuff where we
wanted to sort of prefunding condition
right this is really adding to the
unfunded
liability yeah all right um okay
anyone else wish to talk to us about yes
I see a hand in the back there thank you
you there we go uh my name is Paul Lewis
I'm medically retired out we New
Hampshire I'm one of the two officers
that we know of that would directly
benefit from this bill um just to go off
the number of two New Hampshire is a
very small law enforcement Community
there's three things that can happen if
you get a gun pointed at you right you
can either pass away you can either very
fortunately have uh very minor injuries
which then you could return to work
which does happen and then in my case
and in dh's case the other officer you
have to medically retire due to the
severity of the injuries when that
happens uh we are a community that looks
out for each other anytime there's a big
news story we're right on it Dan reaches
out to me and I reach out to the next
person there's been no one after me in
New Hampshire that has had to medically
retire after a violent injury there has
been in other states and I've reached
out to the officers in the other states
but uh not yet in New Hampshire for me
uh about this bill this is is very
important to me I was working in where
which even with um a college degree I
was making 2150 an hour when I medically
retired my pension went to 29 and with
like the raise of inflation everywhere
it just unsustainable and on top of that
I'm capped at making 19,000 per year so
it just it's a very uh small number that
I'm forced to to live off of right now
and uh I don't get health insurance I
went in front of the town of wear asking
for help with that and they said it's
too expensive go to the marketplace so
now $300 a month from my 2400 that I'm
making is coming out of that and the
number just keeps dwindling and it's
it's very hard for me right now so with
this bill it would it would help me and
it would help a lot of uh future
officers if it were to happen to them
that are in a similar circumstance but
in a 100 Years of New Hampshire law
enforcement it's two that we certainly
know of so it it is rare but it will
hugely impact those those people that it
do help so we're hoping that uh you
understand how helpful this bill can be
and I hope that you can think about
passing
it thank you questions for officer
leis yeah I'll I'll just ask one um if
it's not too personal um looking at you
myself I would say you look like a
person who could work are you is it is
it that serious what happened yeah so I
was hit uh with two bullets in my
dominant arm and after the nerve injury
I I've had five surgeries to try to fix
it my dominant arm is at about 5 to 10%
use I can't write without assistance and
it's been uh four and a half years for
me five surgeries and every time I go
forward and in my progression physically
something happens like in fact two years
ago I was throwing a ball with friends
and my bone re-broke where I took the
bullet and then I went into my fifth
surgery and they found a staff infection
so for that time I needed six weeks of a
um an IV on top of an arm that just had
surgery and it just things keep
happening and and that's like
particularly why this is also important
Dan dhy he's had 19 surgeries in the 10
years so the we want a a separate tear
because these are lifelong injuries that
keep having setbacks for us and we wish
it wasn't that way but due to the
severity it's just it's just what
happens when you're violently injured
thank you other questions no thank you
very much for coming thank you so would
someone like to make a motion
representative Sweeny sh you've ought to
pass all right well I heard the
representative Griffin first so
representative Sweeney moves and
representative Griffin seconds
uh ought to pass and the clerk can call
the
role and I'll remind people you will
need blurbs if you make a
motion representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes chair Wier yes
clerk votes yes representative Lane yes
representative grass yes representative
walner yes representative Maguire yes
okay
90 probably
e
okay it's now 1:20 p.m. and we're here
to talk about Senate Bill 476
commissioner thanks for coming thank you
uh good afternoon for the record my name
is Helen Hanks I'm the commissioner of
the Department of Corrections I thank
you for the opportunity to talk about
Senate Bill 476 the Department of
Corrections has been mindful in all that
we have done in asking for capital
budget infrastructure but we really at a
point uh on behalf of the state
where the New Hampshire state prison for
men needs a replacement and through my
experience in different capacities
within the department including the New
Hampshire correctional facility for
women um waiting for litigation to be
proactive to be involved to move a
project forward is not the way to move
forward and when we asked during the
budget phase for the initial costs to do
the groundwork so that we really know
firmly how much a replacement facility
um would cost the state is really the
right place to begin and the $10 million
which we appreciate um is really not
enough to do more than the geologicals
and we need to um and we're asking for
the um autop pass on Senate Bill 476 to
get the rest of the initial industry
standard costs to do the bid speec
documents to do the Staffing analysis do
the population analysis all of the front
work necessary to lean into this project
in a way that's proactive uh I know the
number uh that we're currently
forecasting for a replacement facility
is is a large number um I respect that
but even if you just turned to slide
five on the informational I sent out
every time I turn a corner even this
last uh nor Easter we all experienced in
April the electrician that is familiar
with our infrastructure at the N state
prison for men literally said you need
to replace the complete electrical
infrastructure at this institution the
linear feet cost of that is not worth
investing in investing in a replacement
facility that is proactive Ive for the
air quality of the staff that work in
that building to promote retention um
and create a healthier environment when
the research already affirms that
working at a correctional facility is
dangerous it is stressful uh we can do
better and then in addition to
continuing to improve the environment
because our mission is Rehabilitation
for those that are incarcerated there
reception and diagnostic was built in
the 1800s we are not supposed to be
functioning in that institution anymore
but we have no choice it is what we have
I have a plumbing ISS I'm not sure I
have a plumber who actually knows how to
work on that plumbing I've not
identified one um and the list goes on
but in the next five years this is what
I can tell you today in the next 10
years there's about $400 million of
infrastructure investment for us to
continue to function in that space it is
a better investment to be proactive to
pass Senate Bill 476 and start working
toward understanding what a replacement
facility would cost and we do have land
behind the New Hampshire correctional
facility for women that we're exploring
and having done the work at the New
Hampshire correctional facility for
women I know it's hard rock but I know
we actually saved half a million dollars
making our own crushing plant and it's a
firm foundation and we can move forward
so with that I do have members uh who
have worked uh several years at the New
Hampshire state prison for men from my
security force and who are leading that
force that are happy to talk about
operations if that um is an inquiry that
comes up from the committee in addition
to my Logistics and uh Finance staff so
with that I certainly entertain
questions thank you commissioner
questions from the committee
representative
wer I'm delighted that you found a good
location I remember what we went through
with the women's prison and that was a
lot of waste of time and effort and I'm
wondering with the um Berlin
prison are we going to have any savings
because we've had a design done and
we've paid money for it and if it works
can we reproduce that or parts of it
without paying it for a whole new design
representative wer I really respect your
question and I'm I'm actually um working
with Partners outside of the state for
example the commissioner Montana is
building a similar sized institution and
if there's some opportunities to
understand in
2024 what uh we can learn from this uh
investment in Senate Bill 476 will help
us get there um reminding everyone it
was built in 2000 and we've learned a
lot more but again there are
opportunities in every ter we make but
we would need to invest in this first
other questions representative
evil um uh thanks for coming having
visited the facility I several years ago
it was also uh it was daunting to see
how much work needed to be done at that
time um how long would uh the
engineering that we would um be
considering funding take and how long
would it be good for because uh
budgeting for $500 million is a
lot thank you uh representative the it's
a good question we already have a
pending U proposed contract for the $10
million that we're waiting to bring
before governor and Council the timing
of this yes but afford US an opportunity
to move that more fluidly we would
expect it would take at least a year of
of this resource to start moving toward
a final proposal but uh I would suspect
no longer than 2 years uh understanding
the timeline and the experience that the
agency already has in building the
women okay so you said you identified a
prison in was it Minnesota that is
similar how many how many inmates will
this prison have the facility that's
being built is in the state of Montana
it's approximately being built for 1400
uh people we have about uh 1100 people
at the Hampshire state prison for men
the investment uh contemplated in Senate
Bill 476 includes forecasting population
population boasts on past experience and
also what the legislature might pass
towards sentencing that would affect uh
population rates including the
classification of those individuals and
talking with the commissioner of Montana
that institution doesn't have all five
levels of classification has uh three so
we are engaged in uh confidential
conversations at this point because it's
about his uh design of the interior of
the facility uh but there are some
definite opportunities to partner with
people already uh doing this across the
country because this 40 million is um
strictly for creating
documents um and so I'm I'm getting
sticker shock on on that number um
and and it seems like
repurposing some existing uh
design I mean there's there's prisons
all over the country besides the one you
just mentioned
um it's got to be much much cheaper than
that so would it make sense even if we
allocate this 40 million to not be so
specific that we only spend this on
documents and not on actual
construction representative McGuire
that's a reasonable question if there's
an opportunity to again and we will work
toward that reduce this expenditure to
the only Point necessary and have any of
those funds then go toward the
construction then we would completely be
that representative evil um how many
contractors in the United States
actually build prisons and are there
services in
demand there are at least um four that I
know are commonly contracted with um
again the carefulness and and me not
talking too deeply about what's going on
in Montana is we have a competitive
bidding process and we would have to as
a state go through that competitive
bidding process but I as the
commissioner Department of Corrections
and mindful that I have opportunities to
talk to people who are already engaged
in this people are not building prisons
every day this just happened to be a un
opportunity to talk about what's
happening in that state um I'm obviously
keenly aware and watching what's
happening in Alabama uh they look like
we looked in 1976 and uh I expect to see
a lot of different things happen in that
state and they're not meeting their
allegedly according to the media health
care and other needs um so again I
understand who's out there but we have
to follow the competitive bidding
state uh yes representative Griffin uh
thank you Mr chair thank
you um I too am in sticker Shar that it
cost $40 million just basically for
plans and
um it really concerns me that it can't
be done for less it's hard to
believe uh buildings a I know a prison
is a different building but buildings
are built all the time complex buildings
and $40 million will be a lot of
building so I don't I don't know whether
they have any comment to that or not
representative Griffin I completely
appreciate your comment I grew up in a
construction family um we pour concrete
those my parents did to feed our Feed Us
on a farm and construction and this this
is a high number but the cost of uh
Correctional facility at this point
really working with our partners at the
Department of Public Works they're
estimating as high as $1,000 per square
foot um I we don't control the
construction Market when it comes to
Corrections um but I am completely
mindful of the work that I did on behalf
of the state in getting the New
Hampshire Correctional Facility women's
project um at a lower number I know we
had to come back and ask for more but
when I started um intervening in that
project they wanted even more um so
designing for efficiency and
responsibility is our charge on behalf
of of what you provide us the
opportunity to do so um we're not
building a 2x4 construction I know you
appreciate that comment it is cement it
is uh it is all of those things that
unfortunately cost more in addition to
uh working on a correctional facility
and having that expertise it's a it's a
high number um and is just the number
market all right so you said $1,000 a
square foot
but um so it's 500 square ft per inmate
is that right representative Maguire I
couldn't just do here's your square feet
for the total allocation because there
are core infrastructure um areas such as
our dining kitchen service our health
services area those areas have different
square foot requirements based on the
operation it's not a one for one square
foot for what we have now and what we
would be looking at in the future
do you know how many square feet this
do I would not be recommending we
replicate the current square footage of
the Hampshire state prison for men given
it's a campus campus style layout so
again I'm not sure it's a number that
will help us in looking at the future
other than affirming for you we've
worked with the Department of Public
Works I mean the numbers we're talking
about here is is half a million dollar
per
[Music]
inmate to build this prison what what's
the ongoing cost what what does your
whole department spend per inmate uh for
operations for operations my last
estimate was around 52,000 per
person can you talk louder
okay h
and so
probably
um if we borrow um
500,000 this says we're going to be
paying back over 20
years uh
[Music]
750,000 um so we're going to pay roughly
another 37 so an inmates going to cost
us $100,000 a year including the
building that's pretty incredible all
right cuz I had always thought you said
72,000 but I always thought it was much
less than that more like 40 no uh I
believe the salary adjustments that
occurred have caused that number to
increase so yes uh the cost of Staff
causes that operational cost to go up I
see how is hiring going lately hiring is
much better than it was post the
pandemic we are holding our own but we
are making up for those those major
losses in 2022 but I appreciate you
asking um and as an aside it's
corrections officer and Employee
Appreciation week so if you see somebody
in Corrections please thank them for
nationally yes representative Griffin
thank you Mr
chair um I know the women's prison is is
uh it was a design that was costly in
terms of Staff would you agree with that
uh representative Griffin I think it
would be fair to say any transition from
gof toown to a larger facility was going
to increase staff uh but we've operated
in it now with less St staff than we
thought we were going to need in the
beginning I know I know when that was
originally built uh uh everyone looked
at the design and said you know that's
going to be very staff
intensive uh is the um the the model
Montana model is are there actual plans
at this point for that prison my
understanding the answer to that is yes
I've not uh been off I've not been able
to look at them I am anxious to see if I
can have an opportunity to look so you
you wouldn't have an opinion of whether
it's efficient in terms of Staff or not
no but representative Griffin what I
would say to you any design in the
future would be cognizant of creating
Staffing efficiency and I think a very
appropriate leading heavily on
technology as a resource and really
investing in our current infrastructure
we're trying to do some of that that
would be transferable to any new
replacement facility as far as
implementing technology thank you
thank thank you uh all right
Representative cambrell no thank you Mr
chair um do you recall what the cost was
for the design of the woman's
prison so that was roughly 10% of
approximately $ 52 million back uh when
that project started in the uh 200
I'm not going to guess on that one but
million is there no follow up okay
um am I right that uh the co operational
cost of Berlin per inmate is much less
than
conquer I don't have a breakout of
operational cost by facility
so I visited both and and my
understanding is one
is um you know like a long Corridor and
then different uh units kind of off that
Corridor and essentially one officer can
can almost control the whole thing by
you know being at the end of that long
Corridor and watching and letting people
into it letting closing the doors
letting them out Etc whereas in in
conquer it's this building that building
the other building and you need an
officer in each or multiple officers in
each am I right or so represent McGuire
the northern Correctional Facility was
designed to be a direct supervision
model so when it opened there was one
officer in each housing unit so each
unit off that long Corridor and then in
uh 2009 2010 I believe we know what
happened in our economy and the
department in order to uh reduce the
impact of layoffs on staff created
what's called a roving Patrol and that
roving Patrol and that physical plant
has allowed for groups of officers to go
to each housing unit um to monitor the
the conduct on those units but to the
point of your question there are lots of
efficiencies that can be gained in
replacing the New Hampshire state prison
for men and utilizing a new design
improved design other than what we
currently function under right now on
the
campus I I wish you would try to um
quantify this question about
Berlin versus conquer we can certainly
look into that sir yeah um because if
you can say I can reduce 72,000 to 50 or
something that helps us pay for this
now let's say we have a design and we
borrow the money to build the prison
what's the construction time
involved I think it would be Prem
premature me to pitch what the
construction time would be until we put
out a bid and received a response back I
can only tell you what it took us to
build an Hampshire correctional facility
for women but representative wer at the
onset pointed out some challenges in
that project that I don't suspect we
will have again given that they looked
at 11 something different designs and I
think four or five different locations
is that correct sir um that's not what
we're trying to do in this in this
program
proposal thank
you all right shall we uh let let's move
on to um uh would our Treasurer like to
borrow good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
State Treasurer Monica
mapelli how much can we borrow well it's
all depend of how how um how much if
your if your budget allows for Debt
Service right so um one of the things as
as when we talk about the capital budget
we typically talk about we give an um
typical recommendation our our estimates
usually use uh about 120 million for the
bium and we that's a common number right
that every I think everybody knows um in
terms of
um um so when when when there are
Appropriations Capital Appropriations in
in the middle of the budget year and an
off year um that usually obviously in uh
for the last capital budget it was um
137 million was authorized which which
included um additional payments for uh
um the university system so that was all
included so you authorize a little more
that we we typically recommend but
that's fine it's the state can certainly
absorb that um so this 40 million will
certainly add to that number right so um
I just want to be mindful of of that
number in terms of the state having the
capacity the state has a capacity to
borrow another 40 million we did not
consider that Debt Service as part of
operating budget but um again um we
calculated the numbers and that's how
much it will cost to add that to our
debt service um right now we're in a
position where the state can certainly
borrow a little more um again our
calculations are based on that number of
120 minut we continue to um in general
estimate and and project that the number
um
to Target that number and it was all
based on um you know your debt in
relation to your revenues right so right
now your revenues are very strong um if
that picture changes over time we we
need to you know uh consider that 120
million of her folks going over that
number which is all um you know it's is
it makes sense since construction costs
have increased and and and and that
makes sense but again your bordering
should be in relation to to your to your
Revenue so again right now we the state
has a capacity I wouldn't have a concern
with with this number right now um uh in
addition to that I've had conversations
with with with commissioner Hanks about
this particular project um this
particular project um the cost of this
project obviously is is um is is pretty
high a lot more than we typically borrow
uh during the bium um and uh one of the
discussions um you know we're going to
once the commissioner has more numbers
and and and in an understanding of the
cost and time and and and all of that
for this project um I will take that
information to try to see if there's
anything else you know if we could
consider this project separate from our
typical um capital budget um because
perhaps this needs to be considered a
separate project look at it in a
different way the useful life of the
prison is going to be a lot more than 20
years so when we borrow funds um you
know we have this requirement of 20
years but perhaps for a project like
this one we could consider 30 years
perhaps you know it just and it will be
okay again because of the useful life of
this assets so those are the
conversations we can have we can
probably again once we understand uh
better the cost and timing um I can
bring that back and speak with some
experts that I work with uh to see if
there are any great ideas out there that
we could consider
so it it my back of the envelope
calculation is if if we were to borrow
the entire cost of the new prison it
would add about 50% to our um to our
debt service payments annually the
entire cost of the 550 million or
whatever yeah and and right so it's it's
it we borrow we typically borrow about
60 million each year um so so an amount
like that obviously the construction is
going to happen over time so that's also
part of the what we want to understand
perhaps it will be 100 million in
addition to what we already borrow so
it's a significant number this is why we
probably want to have a good um handle
on the cost timing and then see how the
numbers those numbers look like but
you're right I think that that would be
it would be an expensive project of
course right but I'm I'm just going off
of you said we're paying 120 million oh
is that a Bend that's the bium right so
we bu for debts debt payments correct so
this would double our I'm sorry so the
120 million is the amount of borrowing
um The Debt Service uh we we are in the
neighborhood of 72 million per year per
fiscal year in terms of all of The Debt
Service that we
have
okay so that doesn't match what I see in
the fiscal note so in the fiscal note so
yeah so you said we're borrowing 120 and
paying over two years yeah 60 a year
right so I guess it depends on how much
debt we have yeah so if
I if I I guess I'm not I'm not probably
with my comments this is borrowing 40
and paying 4.6 per year in addition to
what we already pay in that in addition
to what we already he yes right I see
but but the ongoing stuff is right so
the current debt service is about right
now is about 17 million or I have my
numbers here but
um I can't get you that number but right
so this will be in addition this 4.6
million uh will be in addition to we
were currently so current that service
70 million a year B approximately no a
year a year okay
all
right so um so if I take this number and
multiply it by
12 or 13 right for the whole
prison I don't I don't really have all
of the um yeah we're talking about yeah
so this is almost going to be doubling
our debt service payment that's correct
yeah this is this is why um you know a
potential solution could be to not use
the typical 20 years to just defer a
little bit obviously it's gonna cost
more money but again um it it wouldn't
be unreasonable considering the useful
life of of this
asset um how and we have Debt Service on
the women's present
yes yes uh yes I don't have that number
with
me yes so so current that service is
million it is 73 million actually
because we also pay for the University
system so it is 73 million in that
service that we pay each fiscal year
thank you all right um other
questions yes representative
white congratulations on the increase in
our our credit rating has that helped us
lower the
interest um yes I mean in general it it
does help us but thank you and more than
anything I want to thank you all because
this is the product of your work and
your and your uh good decisions you're
the ones that make the hard decisions
Nami I just I was just the uh the
messenger this time so but thank you
very much um so so yes so in in in
concept yes so um just to give you an
example we you know the C Hampshire
issues bonds only once a year so is
we're not you know we don't have too
many bonds out in the market so um so
our our paper is is pretty um attractive
um just this last time that we went um
we had the sale we had 15 bids so that
um that it was a very good result for
our for sale and and overall yes we did
have a good rate so we we achieved 3.4%
for our last sale so so yes so in
general it just obviously if if our
investors will want to buy our bonds if
we continue with um you know the good
management of our finances but again
this is thanks to all of you and thank
should we talk about this
bill um do we want to do we want to
spend 40 million now do we want to
increase the scope of the bill uh do we
want to borrow this money
or or um spend money we already have
what do you
think yes representative evil well I
mean
I was on public works when the issue
came up with the women's prison and we
hammed and we Haw and we hammed and we
Haw and then all of a sudden there we
lost um well there had been all these
lawsuits right and then the court
basically lost its patience and it said
the time is now either you do it or
we're going to go ahead and start the
construction for you and it was a mad
scramble as uh commissioner Hanks was
saying trying to figure out where to put
it how to build it to get the plans I
mean so I mean I don't think there's
anybody sitting here that doesn't have a
sticker shock from $40
million um I like the thought that maybe
you can reduce it um I'm encouraged that
the treasurer feels that we can
accommodate it off
cycle um I I guess I just feel like
we're over a barrel here and we can't
really put off some sort of
commitment uh to the people that work
there to the prisoners that are there uh
to avoid litigation I just feel we have
to do something to start um moving
forward so I would be in in support of
the bill for all those reasons while
quaking from sticker
shock other
see some nods here yeah okay
representative Sweeny yeah it's feels
like one of those things where we we
have to do it otherwise the cost to just
keep up the existing facility over the
next 10 years will dwarf what the
financing to get the project started um
I do know I mean so we just passed a new
police station in Salem for $38 million
that 10 years ago would have been $20
million but due to inflation and
construction cost increase it's just all
over there I hope we can get a better
interest rate with our credit rating um
but it feels like we're in that rock in
that hard place
okay so Mr Hoffman if this bill passes
presumably before any of this money is
spent the um executive Council looks at
the contracts and and choices of of who
you know and if they find that that the
engineering and design can be done for
less than 40 million then the rest of
the 40 million will either have not
actually been borrowed or will will be
available for construction or other
purposes
correct
instruction which could use the existing
balance I see so is that the way it
works is that once the contract is let
you you then go out and borrow the money
that's correct so we we borrow based on
expenses so once the agenc spending
money um that's when we start bonding
pieces because again it's going to go
over time happen all right would anyone
like to make a motion yes
representative I would make the motion
even though that means I have to write a
committee
report um but under the circumstances I
I think that we really should do this
and the well do I have a
second okay thanks um the only other
thing I would add here is just again
from my experience on public works and
working with the treasurer she gives us
very wise and very conservative
recommendations and
um I guess I have to say that if the
treasurer is telling us that the state
has the capacity to bond for this I
respect your opinion and your
conservative analysis so I feel like we
can um take uh you know solace in that
and feel comfortable with the with the
bonding amount so and I mean we've
discussed this at length there's no
question that we need to move ahead I
guess not not to BL the point but I also
remember in public works one of the
first moves we always made is to try to
get our engineering house in order to
step any further comments on this motion
role
yes
so you you may want to stay for the next
bill we're hoping to send you some more
inmates you
[Laughter]
know about well there's some nasty
with all right all right so let's we we
we have pl we are on time slightly we're
a little late so let's start with the
Senate Bill
right yes okay do I see our attorney
general
yeah good afternoon Mr chair members of
The Division I I don't I don't mean to
um interfere name or
we okay
good I certainly don't mean to PRM
Senator Bradley at the other hearings
we've had on this bill he's introduced
the bill but I'm I'm assuming based on
who's here that I should probably just
speak to
it would you like how would you like me
to proceed would you like me to give an
overview of of what this bill does I
know this is scheduled as a work session
so it just just to be clear I want to
make sure I'm giving you what you need
we're only concerned with the money okay
okay so the 60 million the $60 million
piece
okay so the at present I guess I'll
start with just giving a current status
of the of the settlement fund process we
have received received I think about 450
claims but 163 claims have been resolved
or settled for a total of about $82
million of the fund um the fund has2 or3
million in administrative expenses that
have been expended since late 2022 so
there's roughly $15 million left in the
fund so the 60 million is intended to
replenish the fund um but it also goes
along I think for this bill in
particular to understand the 60 million
it's important to understand some of the
major changes that are being made to the
settlement fund
process so without going over all of the
background on how this came to be
because I think at this point the
legislature is fairly familiar with it
but I'm happy to take questions um as
you know when the YDC settlement fund
process was first set up and when the
first bill passed back in 2022 we did
not have broad consensus on the bill I
think from the Attorney General's office
perspective we felt that the the bill
set up a victim centered and Trauma
informed process that would be
appropriate for many of the victims at
YDC but we hadn't achieved broad
consensus the bill that's before you
makes some changes to that process that
now come with agreement from Nixon
Peabody and Russ Riley who represent you
know 90 plus% of the
claimants a big there were three main
reasons why Nixon Peabody and Russ Riley
had not agreed to recommend this process
to the vast majority of their clients
before um one of them was just the scope
of the bill what the scope of the claims
process what types of uh harms and
abuses the claims process covered um
another major Point were the Caps so
what the Caps were at they thought the
Caps were too low and then a third major
point was just the process and how it
worked they felt the process was too
complicated and while we we felt that it
was a fairly streamlined process
certainly compared to the traditional
litigation process they felt the process
was still too complicated so this bill
makes a number of changes to address
those concerns um the first thing the
bill does is it raises the caps for
egregious sexual abuse from 1.5 million
to 2.5 million um we expect that
egregious cases will be a fairly you
know certainly the distinct minority of
cases that come through the fund um
perhaps the best way to illustrate that
is that right now the number of claims
that have been resolved at the cap it's
about 10 or 11 out of 163 so it's a
fairly small percentage of claims that I
think would be subject to that increased
overall cap um the bill also expands the
scope of the fund to expand the
definition of sexual abuse and include
other things
it also creates a second category of
abuse that's no longer just physical
abuse it's physical abuse plus other
things so that will now be a category of
other
abuse and the in exchange for that in
exchange for expanding the scope and
increasing the caps in certain places
the bill provides that the administrator
will now be empowered to award claims in
annual installments so right now Claims
can only be awarded in lumps sums but
going forward if this bill passes the
administrator will be empowered to award
claims and annual installments and the
bill will also impose a $75 million per
fiscal year cap on the amount of money
that can be paid out of the fund so that
that sort of an exchange for raising the
caps and expanding the scope to get more
people to come in we have those
safeguards that at least protects the
state from having this become a a
runaway process in which hundreds of
millions of dollars get exp ended at any
one fiscal year there will still be an
option for for the administrator to come
to the fiscal committee and to the
governor and councel to raise that limit
in any given fiscal year but there will
be those safeguards in place so that if
there the bill you know won't cause the
state to spend a lot more money than it
has and I would expect that whether the
fiscal committee or the governor and
Council would agree to increase that
limit in any given fiscal year that will
depend on how the state's Finance look
at that point in time so that those are
the basics and Mr chair just because you
said you were only really concerned with
the money I just I'm I wanted to hit
those points I'm happy to answer other
questions but the $60
million that was our estimate provided
to the Senate at the amount of money
that we thought
would hopefully get us through fiscal
year 25 so between now and the end of
fiscal year 25 given that going forward
if this bill passes payments could be
awarded in annual installments as I said
there's about 15 million left in the
fund now if we add 60 million that would
get it up to 75 million and I expect
that we'll that will be close to the
amount we need to get through the end of
fisal year 25 given that if this bill
passes we're going to have to go back
through the fiscal committee to change
the guidelines and we expect that the
claims process will either slow down
significantly or even be put on pause
for a time while we rewrite the
guidelines to match the revisions in the
bill so all that said that's really what
that's where the number 60 million comes
from and I'm happy to answer any
questions on other details of the bill
or or anything else about this process
thank you so did I hear you say that
it's about a half million settlement per
case on average yes that's correct okay
and um and how many cases are there Al
together there have been 450 claims
filed so far we we know that Nixon puddy
and Russ Riley represent 1300 1,400
people now they've already filed some of
those claims in the fund but all
together I would say we're probably
looking at close to 1,500 claims maybe
more that could come through the process
it could be less because um the
plaintiff's count attorneys have
committed that with these changes they'd
recommend the process to the vast
majority of their clients but we're
certainly looking at a number between
1,000 and 2,000 and I think it's at the
end of the day when this is all said and
done I would estimate we're going to be
somewhere in the 1500 claims range but
it's difficult we will not know until
the the deadline closes next next June
2025 1,500 claims so we're talking about
$750
it and and yet there's only a
dozen
um criminals involved in
this so I mean is it really possible for
them to
move yeah well so 11 individuals have
been criminally charged I think what you
have to remember is that these types of
cases are very difficult criminal cases
to bring even when the alleged abuse
happened last week let alone decades ago
um there are also many allegations that
stem stem from a time when the statute
of limitations to bring any criminal
charges has has long passed so I I I
think it is you know it that's what
makes what happened here or it's one of
the things that makes what happened here
so difficult to Grapple with we're
talking about a large span of time I
mean we have allegations from the 60s so
60s 7s 80s 90s early
2000s and once you get back past the
1990s any statute limitations for
criminal cases would have would have
long passed so I I I don't think it's
uh as much as it may be tempting un I
don't think you can really
use the number of viable criminal cases
to make a reasonable estimate as to the
number of viable and credible
allegations of abuse that occurred there
over the many decades that we're talking
about why was there such a delay between
the the crimes and
now and and coming coming to light
recently well that's you know that's a
question I will never completely be able
to answer but I I think that you know
that has a lot to do with the fact that
until the first couple of victims came
forward the others didn't didn't have
the courage to come forward so I I think
that that's part of the reason that
explains the delay um but you know
beyond that that's that's something
that's difficult to answer I mean it's
not uncommon for victims of sexual abuse
especially to to to take many years to
come to terms with what happened to them
and to have the courage to to come
forward and for kids who might have been
in in custody in a juvenile detention
center this is a population that's
particularly susceptible to think that
no one would ever believe them thank
representative Camal thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking the question uh uh
to dat have any of the claims been
rejected as unfounded so they got paid
nothing
there have been claims that have been
that have not been paid anything there
have also been many claims who have got
whose Awards have been much less than
the amount they they claimed so that I
mean it brings up an important point
this is not a process in which you just
come through you say this happened and
you get paid out for for what you claim
um we right now for the even the claims
that have been resolved they've been the
amounts that have been paid out are
close to half of what was actually
claimed and as more claims come in you
know we'll we'll get a sense of what the
true average will be I don't think it's
guaranteed to say the average will
maintain at 500,000 I mean you may it
even though we know that you know a
thousand plus lawsuits have been filed
it's not until we see the actual details
of a claim in writing that it can really
be evaluated but that that was a long
answer to your question but yes some
claims have been paid nothing and many
many many claims have been paid
significantly less than the original
amount
claimed thank you um yeah the reason I
asked is I just wanted to make sure it's
not a situation where anybody that comes
forward that had been there makes a
claim and then for convenience sake we
pay them out just to make them go away
that's not the case right no that is
you representative Lane
thank you for taking my question um what
would the impact of the recent case that
was that awarded $38 million have on
this whole thing because I know as a
plainist attorney I would be hesitant to
recommend to settle for this amount with
that out there I know it's not a final
one but just how does that impact all of
this yeah so I I would answer that in a
couple ways one
you know I think it's safe to say that
that the case that was just tried was
one of the most egregious if not
egregious cases that that we would see
from YDC um Second and I don't you know
we've still got and I know you'll
understand this we've still got you know
pending litigation arguments in front of
Judge shman and and I'm sure you've seen
the news about our position on on the
the cap applying but you know
we that the case is a good example of
the risks of litigation either way right
the jury came back with a high damages
number but they also came back with a
finding of of one incident and um you
know we feel very strongly that their
finding of one incident should and will
hold and that the actual judgment in the
case will be
$475,000 um beyond that I'm not going to
say you know I'm not going to say more
because I don't want to be seen to be
arguing our case here in this form but
but to answer your question the the
I I think it we don't know for sure what
impact that will have on how many
claimants come through but I do think
that that that case was it's a it was a
really difficult case I
mean you know it's an understatement to
say that I it was the most difficult for
Mr Mian and can't imagine what he what
he went through um it was that case was
an example of how difficult it could be
to try any one of these cases and the
risks involved for either the plaintiff
or the defense in going to trial in one
of these
cases yeah is there a legal case being
made against us that we should not be
able to set
caps um because it just it sort of
seems to some extent self-serving for us
as
the defendant yeah thank you to um to
say to make a a law that here's all we
can pay right you know what I mean um
not that I think the taxpayers is in any
way responsible in some sense I don't
know thank
you so so is that it is somebody making
that case against us that that we cannot
make a cap that case may very well be
made at some point you know in my role
as the Attorney General I I certainly
would would not agree with that legal
position if someone took it I believe
it's ultimately up to the legislature to
determine to what extent you know the
state is going to wave sovereign
immunity But to answer your question
that case has not been explicitly made
up to this point but but it could be
made as we move forward in the
litigation piece of this have there been
similar cases in other states or
nationally that bear on this on the way
this settlement is going
[Music]
forward what do you mean the way you
know with regard to litigation over Caps
or just handling something like this
over caps on cases like this on the
cases of abuse of
children I off the top of my head I'm
not I would say I'm not well-versed
enough in litigation regarding uh caps
that states have P have placed on on you
know the liability of a state but I do
think there is pretty strong case law
that supports the concept of sovereign
immunity and at the end of the day what
a cap is is the state waving sovereign
immunity up to a point because the state
actually I think the state would have
the right to to not wave sovereign
immunity at all so to not allow any
recovery against the state but the state
that all right thank you um any other
questions uh represent
W just a really quick one so I know that
in this bill we're changing that now we
can pay annually is that the claimant
can make that choice or is that the way
all payments will be
made the all payments will not
necessarily be be made in annual
installments but it will now be up to
the administrator and it whereas before
it was it was completely the clayman's
choice the administ Ator can now require
it as part of the administrator's job to
sort of manage the fund and ensure that
no more than 75 million goes out in any
one
year
y How could a jury even come up with a
figure like $38 million it makes no
sense it doesn't help the person they're
just going to waste the money the
lawyers are going to come in for a big
piece of it and think whoopy we'll get
more cases like this I mean I
mean was the jury instructed as to what
money would be used or how would it be
used or how how you even can claim
obviously the average person if they
were working hard and keeping their nose
clean might make over a million dollars
in a
lifetime somebody got up to claim oh
he'd lost $2 million in his lifetime
because of his earnings an exceptionable
person will make a couple of million
dollars in their lifetime but not if
they've been in trouble and hadn't
gotten any advanced
qualifications and and be work hard to
get enough that but but some of these
figures just Boggle the mind and then I
wonder why the your team didn't even
bring the reality to it this jury it's
crazy what they came up with well I'm
I'm going to be careful on commenting on
on where the jury landed but but I will
say um you know on behalf of our team I
I mean I couldn't be prouder of the work
our trial team did in this case and as
you imagine it was a very difficult case
for attorneys from the Department of
Justice to have to try it's
not many times at the doj you know our
team is wearing the white hat we're
either Prosecuting offenders or we're
we're playing offense to protect the
public and having to uh defend the state
in a case like this is a it's a
complicated Endeavor it's difficult
Endeavor I think the trial team did a
great job and the trial team certainly
made a strong case and I bet you if
plaintiff's council were here they they
would tell you that um as as far as
where the jury landed you know that that
could be the subject of certainly the
subject of post-trial proceedings and
and appell proceedings and and even
aside from that I want to be careful
with with commenting on on how the jury
came up with what they came up with
interestingly we had never heard the
475,000
well I with respect to that
representative I would say that I I
certainly have discussed that cap when
I've been before the legislature and
when I've talked about this this
settlement process and uh it's it's in
the statute and and that was an issue
that certainly was discussed in depth
and in detail in front of the judge in
this case and the judge decided that the
jury would not be instructed on the cap
but but I I think that I've I've
definitely discussed the cap when I've
been before the legislature
other questions seeing none thank you
very much General froma thank you are
there others who would like to speak to
591 yes no
thank you Mr chairman again um for the
record Cate Treasurer Monica mapelli um
I do not have any comments as to the
purpose of of this bill um I understand
um I understand what it's being uh um
this amendment drafted um the only
comment I have um is um relative to the
bond and authorization um my only um
which it could be understandable that uh
perhaps there will be um uh the opport
to to finance some of this cost as as um
some of the um right now we we have
aound through this bill there's a
particular estimate as to how much
perhaps um the ministerial can spend um
so there are only two ways to fund this
uh through Appropriations or uh through
the add of bonds so the the only comment
I have is for you to consider is um
typically we see in bills uh abondon
authorization amount The reason an
authorization amount is helpful is
because um I have to budget for Debt
Service so this will be Debt Service
that would be paid uh with General funds
um the other purpose um the other uh
reason why it's important to have an
appropriate U an authorization amount is
because I have to calculate the debt
limit um every year there's a there's a
requirement I say
6C um that um I have to calculate uh a
Deb limit um so you know how much you're
able to borrow each year um so because
of that I think it will be important to
have a better understanding as to that
uh borrowing uh amount that you may
consider whether in the aggregate or or
annually um so the bill is um silent on
that and that would be my only comment
for you to consider and if if it's not
through this particular bill um we will
probably have to have the same
conversation uh when we're trying to
budget for the next bium um just because
we will have to have a better picture as
to how much we're going to be able to
borrow uh if you're considering
borrowing again um I I don't know um how
the you know the legislature will will
try to fund some of how to replenish
this fund going forward um there are
some unknowns uh I understand that part
too um but again just something for you
to consider as you're discussing this
bill um typically we see a bond and
authorization amount for every Capital
appropriation this one is not a capital
appropriation it will be borrowing to
try to fund or replenish this fund um
another piece I just want to mention for
your for your knowledge and again this
this perhaps could be discussed in the
future but um any borrowing related to
um uh for this purpose as the bill has
written uh it will have to be a taxable
taxable debt just because uh this is not
to benefit the state directly this would
be to benefit um uh the members uh that
will benefit from this fund U the
beneficiaries of this fund so uh for
that typically a little the debt is a
little um more expensive than tax and
sub debt so something for you to
consider as your as you're funding this
um this um for this purpose
um yes thank you so I I think this is an
appropriate time to bring forward my
Amendment
because I agree with you that this is
maybe not an appropriate thing to borrow
money
for and and it could be part of the
planning right so I think part of what I
I I also wanted to mention
is it could it could be appropriate to
borrow for this purpose and perhaps you
can create design a plan that you know
could have a combination of
Appropriations and finance and finance
and a portion of it
um so that could be a perhaps an
appropriate plan to proceed I think what
will be important typically um it is it
is helpful to know and try to estimate
how much you want to borrow we typically
as I mentioned previously as when I was
speaking before you is we we developed
the data affability study we tried to
project um how much we're going to
borrow how much the general fund is
going to pay and and so these will be
part of that those calculations that we
prepare um but again this is all if you
wanted to do some borrowing related to
this this bill so thank you
um so I I agree so I I think that
it's there's a big difference between
this bill and the previous one and that
is I think it's appropriate to borrow to
for for
um Capital Equipment and goods and
things like like roads and prisons and
stuff that's that's going to be used
over long periods of time houses right
but it's not appropriate to borrow money
for
expenses and I see this as a little bit
more like an expense right there's going
to be a a certain amount that we have to
spend but
um but it's not something it's it's
something really that's the the the
obligation of in some sense past
taxpayers or current ones and not future
ones and so
therefore um it's not really appropriate
to borrow so the question is where do we
have $60
million and as you all know we have it
in the education trust fund and so
does I guessed you
might that's a shock yeah all right any
any
comments any no all right all right so
I'm I'm going to move um ought to pass
with amendment I guess and um don't we
vote on the amendment first yeah yeah
but I'm I'm moving that and so I'll move
all right any comments on the
amendment representative grass if if
this goes to the floor of the house and
your amendment is rejected where does it
leave us standing well then it would
simply be if if it was ought to if the
committee was assuming the committee was
ought to pass with Amendment then and
the amendment's rejected then there's
ought to pass I obviously there could be
floor amendments right the basic bill
that we have here would be next up so
yeah
representative Griffin I I think there
some is some logic in charging the
education trust fund because most of
these victims were were U school
AG children for the most part they were
teenagers high
it I I know I'm only a substitute but
but um you get to vote I get to vote and
um I my feeling is that until we get
through having set as a substitute for
long-term on education until we get the
lawsuits about adequate funding for
schools in the state and until we
adequately fund them I don't think we
should be robbing Peter to pay Paul and
I don't um understand the
analysis of taking money that we've put
aside for education and using it to pay
for what is amounting to negligence on
the state's part and its administration
of the Youth Detention
Center thank
you um so she representative Lane brings
up an interesting question um I don't
know if General formela would like to
say anything about the education
you so I I I guess my answer on that
might be somewhat disappointing I mean I
I think it's best not to get in really
get into the substance substance of the
education funding
lawsuits other than to say I I could
understand the position that um you
might not want to mess with the
education trust fund while that's
pending but I you know I I didn't come
prepared today to think that through
very deeply I I would just point out
when it comes to taking money from the
education trust fund the other thing to
keep in mind is that you know if some of
that money came from from the lottery
the lottery funds cannot be diverted
away from the education trust fund so
you would just want to make sure that if
you're diverting $60 million away that
you're not you're not taking Lottery
money and I I wouldn't be in a position
to do that analysis right right here
sitting here but that that' just be
another point I'd make um given that the
bonding Authority was discussed too I
thought I'd just make a point with that
you know the way the Bill's drafted it's
not saying that the state will borrow
anything it just contemplates that the
legislature and the governor and Council
in a given year might dis side to borrow
borrow money to replenish the settlement
fund as opposed to just a you know um
taking money from funds other not
otherwise appropriated but other than
that I wouldn't I'm not sure it's my
place to comment on on this amendment
because it just it seems that it's just
the legislature making a policy decision
on where to pull funds from and as long
as you keep in mind the Constitutional
restrictions on how to use Lottery money
I think that's a decision that really is
up to you
thank you
um my argument back on that specific
point would be the amount we sent to
schools is way way greater than the
total amount of Lottery money and so
therefore what we're spending here would
be what other funds that that are not
Lottery funds I mean presumably we could
put some kind of line in here but the
money is fungible right so there's
there's no you know there's there's no
color on one dollar versus another that
says this came from the lottery and this
came from you know what I mean so yeah
yes money is absolutely fungible and and
I think that would probably be a
question for the LBA if anyone to take a
look at at you know I I went to law
numbers further
discussion representative evil without
commenting specifically on this uh what
does it take to
get into the rainy day fund and is this
know um Mr Hoffman do you
know I'm sorry you were
asking well there's also uh rainy day
fund money and I was curious how one
accesses dives into the
rain huh
it's well
all right M treasurer do you want to
you thank you for the question um so
that just as a reminder that the Rainy
Define is a reserve uh and by law it
needs to be it can only be accessed if
there is a deficit at the end of the
bium so uh normally you will you know
it's not a typical process there is a
proced procedure yes that um I forget
his um a number that needs to be passed
in order to to withdraw um funds from
the rainy day fund before the end of the
biannual but the typical process is just
in the event of a deficit or um if the
state doesn't um collect enough Revenue
that's when mechanically you can you
could potentially access funds for the
rainy day fund but it's not uh what we
so it's a it's a it's a a sensitive
topic when it comes to this discussing
to investors and the rating agencies
because one of the reasons we received
the rating um the upgrade um the because
we have H strong reserves right now so
strong cash reserves was an important
part of of the upgrade that we received
so just hopefully that answers the
question representa wner yes thank you
when we originally set up the settlement
fund wasn't the first $100 million that
we deposited in into that fund wasn't
that from the rainy day fund it was it
was an action of law in um U which we it
was completely understood why um that
was taken at the time it was a policy
decision uh one of the concerns I raised
at that time was you know perhaps I was
trying to suggest if maybe it could be
could have been taken from some other
place just because I know how sensitive
the fact that is sensitive topic again I
have to respond to questions from
investors from rating agencies you know
why are we taking the money from that
pot if we have other pots of money right
so so for the most part my my
recommendation is you you have your
reserves you know we all have emergency
funds so should have emergency funds so
that's what the you know the rating fund
should should function as that as a an
emergency
fund wner sorry
W my recollection on the rainy day fund
there two times you can take the money
out
either the revenue comes up less than we
assumed when we made the budget or the
spending was more than the budget called
for those are the two times you get in
the rainy day funds that is correct so
my understanding is that if
um revenue is low or lower than expected
in the budget the governor is both
is authorized to and obligated to spend
less by by cancelling whatever he can to
make us not run out of money is that
right that is also an option of course
um control and expenditures before the
end of the banum yes and we did that it
was done during the uh pandemic time it
was it was a difficult time there was uh
there were some um limitations on the
amount of spending and also there was
there was the plan to to tap into the
rain fund at point but um just the
economy changed and and we receive uh
funds from the federal from the federal
government at that point things just
recovering representative eel and then
representative Lane I I just wondered
what was currently in the rainy day fund
do you know I believe it's two um 292
million
dollar uh thank you um
what are are there other reserves that
you mentioned other reserves when you
were talking would there be other
reserves that we could take this money
from no thank you for the question no so
the rain f is really the the one Reserve
we have I mean I was was speaking of
strong reserves because we we have a
strong cash position we still have oura
funds but in reality everything has been
appropriated through the budget process
um probably the only items that have not
been appropriated are the Surplus
revenue or the additional Revenue we
have received this year uh which is um
th those are the funds the LBA tracks
and those are the funds that are perhaps
with all the various Appropriations that
the legislature is considering during
this off year um those will be funds
that could be used for those additional
Appropriations that were not part of the
operating
budget represent grass uh you made a
statement that you could take the funds
out of the rainy day fund by two two
ways one is that revenues are too low or
expenditures too high but when
addressing representative walner
question was she said where did the
100,000 $100 million come from you said
it was done by legislative action so
there was actually a third way we could
take the money out by legislative action
that that is correct that is correct it
wouldn't be something I will recommend
but that is that is
a you're
welcome so this is a question for the
LBA the house passed two bills that put
large expenses on the education trust
fund one for just general uh 68 million
if I remember right higher adequate
education payments the other one was I
think about $18 million for special
education and I I looked at the status
of uh this I saw the spe special
education bill I think is is SK uh
recommended interim study in this in the
Senate do you know what the the other
is in the Senate finance
committee and I don't believe they've
yet thank you other discussion on the
amendment
amendment so uh there's a motion on
amendment number 1832
H uh representative
Maguire yes represent Griffin yes Sween
yes represent cell
yeser yes CL votes no representative Lan
no representative grassy no uh
no called on representa okay so it's 5
to
four all right motion
now pass
am motions now a to pass as amended by
1832 H further discussion on
that none clerk can
okay representative Griffin yes
representative s yes
representative
yes yes v no representative Lane
no
yes we're way past 2 o' so we can start
on Sate Bill 553
all you leaving not leaving leaving I
I
so I asked Melissa to uh create a little
packet of the relevant laws in case
anybody would like to
know
um you know read existing law and so on
um it turns out it's it's a little weird
that
um the the this this uh fund has been
been in existence since
1991 but it's only been under the
treasurer since last year it previously
had been under the banking commissioner
so that may be why the treasurer doesn't
have rules and things like that right
because it's it's it hasn't been very
long so um but in any case the the
language in the law is essentially the
same as it was under the banking
commissioner um for many many you know
well over 30 years so um but that
information's in in this but and so I
guess that representative Sweeney would
like to
offer
Amendment 1843 1843 and okay
representative evil a second and we'll
speak to his motion perect thank you
very much Mr chairman uh so this was the
bill that we were about to inter room
study yesterday and we we just wanted to
give stakeholders one more day sort of
discuss it with the treasurer uh this
amendment represents a compromise
between the proponents of the
legislation and the treasurer in order
to make this uh from the original bill
which was going to mandate 100% of the
of P dip into invested in New Hampshire
uh this is an encouragement bill now
that will simply ask them to strive that
no less than 30% be invested in New
Hampshire uh but there is no requirement
within the within this amendment or or
once we amend the legislation that would
actually require uh the investment be in
New Hampshire but it will just show the
legislative intent and encouragement
that the fund be partially invested in
the state of New Hampshire uh while
still maintaining that the and I'll
quote directly the investment advisor
selected by the state treasurer and
advisory committee shall achieve and
maintain the highest attainable rating
for stable value local government
investment pools uh right above that we
say the investment advisor selected by
the state treasur and advisory committee
shall strive to maintain no less than
30% of the funds held by the public
deposit investment pool in insured or
collateralized deposits meet the
requirements of RSA
68i and 68 I a so the real emphasis to
the amendment is that their main
priority is to obtain the highest
attainable rating for stable value local
government investment pools and while
striving to make sure that 30% meet the
original intent of the bill um there is
an update to the definition of ratings
in the bill in the amendment uh further
conversations with the treasurer that I
would just want to read in uh to this
amendment uh as a friendly Amendment
instead of lines 25 through 27 for the
purposes uh striking that and just say
the credit rating is an indication of
the ability to preserve Principle as
determined by a nationally recognized
statistical ratings organization just to
provide that definition as to what
credit rating in the in the terms of
this bill is uh and for Monday's meeting
I'll have a an updated Amendment with
that directly in it but that is I think
there we we heard a lot about people
wanting to protect pip as it is we heard
from from stakeholders of the the value
that would be added to New Hampshire's
economy with with more money invested in
the state of New Hampshire I think this
amendment can can protect PP while also
investing in our own economy um and it's
a good Middle Road for for the problem
that's been uh brought forward to us
thank you thank you um representative
Griffin thank you Mr
chair um I looked at the
amendment I I'm still very unhappy with
the shells strive and the
30% I think now that we know the history
of uh the fund and the changes in the
law that were made to it last
year uh we should give the uh the fund
administrator and the policy committee
time to develop policies on their own
that may encourage investment in in New
Hampshire and still maintain the safety
of the fund and not
necessarily Target a certain percentage
so I will be voting no against the
amendment and supporting a motion to uh
represent Cal thank you Mr chair in
reading the amendment I believe that
this amendment is that encouragement for
them to look at their policies and it is
not a mandate therefore I would be
supporting
it representative grassy yes thank you
Mr chairman um I have to to disagree I
first of all I I this bill should have
went to Commerce instead of here where
they have a little more experience in
dealing with banking issues and
investment issues but but secondly I
think that you know one of the first
things I think was said is that this is
an agreement was reached between the
parties uh but it was the treasurer and
the banking industry that it was reached
was where were the cities and towns that
spoke against this bill where were they
in that negotiations I think that one of
the things that we left out and what
I've received a number of phone calls
with people that I've worked with in the
past for the small cities and towns who
do not have the ability to invest on
their own um and and and get rates that
they're able to get through the pool and
I think that that's the important thing
is that until we hear from them I don't
think I can support this and I would
rather see this go to interim study so
that we can take a look and and bring
the cities and towns who opposed the
original bill into this negotiation so
we can sit down and maybe we can find an
agreement between everybody but
negotiations between the bank and the
treasurer leaves out all those small
communities that we
represent thank you further
discussion no all right yeah I'm uh I'm
with uh Representatives Griffin and
grassy on this um I tend to
think this is a very successful program
all the people we spoke to who use it
like it don't want it change we had
another two letters today one from uh
Randolph one from coas County both say
don't make any
changes you know I think you know 30% of
a mistake is still
mistake so
um so I'm going to be voting no also all
right what further discussion
representative evil yeah um I agreed to
sign on to the amendment with uh rep
representative Sweeney and I thank him
for bringing it Forward I I mean as I
read this this is purely an
encouragement um approach uh
encouragement that I was persuaded was
important and needed based on the
testimony that we heard during the
original hearing and then as far as the
I mean I'm very respectful of the
municipalities I didn't see that the New
Hampshire Municipal Association took a
position on this I know they didn't um
but the other important Point here is if
there's concerns about return for the P
dip if you invest locally there's a
requirement here that they shall achieve
and maintain the highest attainable
rating uh for the pools so I think that
answers the return concern and for that
reason um I will be supporting the
amendment thank you I'll just I'll just
point out rating here is about uh safety
it is not about return as far as I I am
believe and and interestingly enough
none of the language in law for many
many years said said anything about
return you know it didn't say you know
you would expect it to say you
know achieve the highest possible return
given an adequate level of safety or
something like that but it actually
didn't say any of that it just said to
the advisory committee you come up with
criteria and that's what they naturally
did so anyway um let's have a vote I
guess are we ready when the clerk is
ready yep okay all right um uh okay this
is just on the amend so
1843 H representative Griffin no
representative Sweeney yes
representative Camrose yes
representative Wier no clerk Vates yes
representative Lane yes yes
representative grassy no representative
walner yes and representative Maguire no
Mr chairman I move interim study so the
bill is amended I think we are already
on op to pass with this amendment no no
no no no the am I made the I made the
motion right interim study with the
amendment to
pass I don't know I guess I'm not have
been a chair long enough to answer this
wer moving interim study is in order
okay all right well I don't have a sheet
all right I presumably the five people
who voted for the amendment can vote no
on an interim study if they want
to how do you amend an interim study you
don't it's not an that's
motion I don't think so should I call
the all right
um let me call them because you know way
pass let let's recess until 5 of: new
interim ready all right I'm going to get
another
she not
even
for
e
and you know if the if that fails then
we can look for other motions and and uh
if it succeeds then the minority can
recommend interim study right and write
a blurb and all that stuff so okay so
let's vote on ought to pass with
Amendment okay um representative Griffin
no
yes
no do we have any other business
today all right we'll see you all at one
o'clock tomorrow or or is it noon if we
have a
caucus I'm not tomorrow Monday yeah
Monday no no yes we do have session
sorry
s right right right so so we have
session tomorrow 9:00 cus uh whatever
10:00 session but but as as a finance
committee Monday at 1 or noon if you
have a caucus full Finance full Finance
all these bills and and Monday is
exclusively division
one all 14 of our bills or whatever
go